okay today Brady we're going to look at
Smith numbers and Smith numbers were
born in an unusual place they were born
in a telephone directory when somebody
was looking up the phone number of their
brother-in-law and wrote down the number
and then realized it had some unusual
properties for nine three seven seven
seven five and that's a Smith number
that's a Smith number and whose number
was it it was in fact Harold Smith and
he was I think the brother-in-law of
Albert we Lansky who was trying to
contact him and found him in the phone
directory so we'll ants c'mere the
breakthrough in realizing that there was
some nice property about this particular
number so this is perhaps a bit big to
start off with in defining a Smith
number but a Smith number is it is a
special number the sum of the integers
that make up the number is the same as
the sum of the prime factors of the
number 27 is a Smith number well first
of all let me just write out the prime
factors of 27 so 27 can be written in
the following way three times three
times three okay
now let me do the following add these
two numbers together that make it of 427
two plus seven and you'll notice then
that's equal to the sum of the prime
factors 3 plus 3 plus 3 which equals 9
and that's what makes up the Smith
number a famous one the one that you've
already covered in number files which is
the beast number six six six so that
breaks into 2 times 3 times 3 times 37
ok if you multiply these together you'll
get back 666 now let's add these digits
together so 6 plus 6 plus 6 and that is
the same as 2 plus 3 plus 3 and now
comes the the subtle bit you don't add
37 you break 37
up into its digits so let me put three
plus seven and hopefully this works 6
plus 6 plus 6 is 18 2 plus 3 is 5 plus 3
is 8 plus 3 is 11 plus 7 is 18 and so
that's why 6 6 6 is also a Smith number
let's go to the original Smith number
and let's have a go at that one
what gets me is how he decided he
realized that this was going to this was
going to work first of all get the prime
factors okay so it's 3 times 5 times 5
times 65,000 837 it's that bit that I
really think is really neat
what we can do is add up the digits that
make up the number okay 4 plus 9 plus 3
plus 5 and this should equal 3 plus 5
plus 5 plus and then we do this trick
right we break this up into its
individual digits see 3 plus 7 I hope
this works
ready otherwise I'm looking a right
idiot 4 plus 9 is 13 plus 3 is 16 plus 5
is 42 what I do yay okay and let me
confidently write 42 there and now let's
check if it works here 5 plus 5 is 13
plus 10 plus 3 is 13 plus 10 is 42 it
worked okay just know that's a Smith
know you like those ones I like that
number I think it's really nice really
do you like about it and I like the fact
that first of all it's a number where
you you've broken it down into its these
are I'm a physicist right I believe in
building blocks quarks the building
blocks of matter these are the building
blocks of mathematics right the prime
numbers are the building blocks so you
first of all can break it down into
those prime numbers and then somehow by
just adding together these prime numbers
you get a property of the original
number over and over and above the
original property which was you know you
multiply the primes
it just has a nice additional feature to
it for nine three seven seven seven five
am i speaking to this person let's see
what happens well he's probably had it
disconnected he's so cheesed off with
people ringing him what really blew me
away was when I discovered what the
biggest nan Smith number is and I
thought I'd write that one down for you
because I'm not sure how they were able
to check it all okay it's a big one so
10 to the power 1030 1-1 that one's very
important okay that's all multiplying
this the following 10 to the power four
thousand five hundred and ninety four
plus three times ten to the twenty two
thousand two hundred and ninety seven
plus one again and all of that bracket
is raised to the power one thousand four
hundred and seventy six and that's not
the end of it that then all gets
multiplied by 10 to the power 3 million
nine hundred and thirteen thousand two
hundred and ten and this is the largest
known Smith number input in fact it's
given as in terms of the little mass
it's given us 16 times 100 to the power
n where I'm going to let this number n
vary so if n is zero